im oberbayerischen Fürstenfeldbruck
fehlen wie überall Lehrkräfte deshalb
hat der Freistaat Gertraud Schmidt
inständig gebeten sie möge doch bitte
aus dem Ruhestand zurückkehren die
pensionierte Grundschullehrerin hat
sofort ja gesagt weil sie aber zu viele
Stunden unterrichtet habe muss sie jetzt
knapp 10.000 € ans Land zurückzahlen ich
finde es einfach bodenlos und ich fühle
mich auch von meinem Freistaat wenn er
Bürgerin im Stich gelassen aber ganz
ganz immens April 2020 bekommt Gertraud
Schmidt Post wegen des eklatanten
Lehrermangels möge sie bitte wieder
unterrichten so der Kultusminister vor
ihrem Ruhestand war sie mit Leib und
Seele Lehrerin sie kehrt gerne in die
Schule zurück zunächst für zehn
Wochenstunden
2022 stockt sie dann auf 14 auf auch das
macht sie gern sie soll Kindern helfen
die wegen Corona den Anschluss verloren
haben doch diese zusätzlichen Stunden
werden zum Problem denn als pensionierte
Beamtin verdient sie jetzt mehr dazu als
sie darf das Landesamt für Finanzen
wirft ihr sogar ungerechtfertigte
Bereicherung vor
womit habe ich ich persönlich bereichert
ich bin in der Schule gegangen um Kinder
die auf der Strecke geblieben sind
ukrainischen Kindern die rein gedrängt
sind in unser Schulsystem ein bisschen
sprachlich auf die Beine zu helfen sie
wird sich doch es hilft alles nichts die
Behörde fordert sie auf fast 10.000 Euro
zurückzuzahlen in Fürstenfeldbruck
schlagen die Wellen hoch mich ärgert das
total weil er Frau Schmidt sich bereit
erklärt hat auszuhelfen und wird jetzt
bestraft dafür das waren viele Stunden
die ausgefallen sind Klassen wurden
geteilt und wenn man dann
doch den Druck hat Leute herzukriegen um
die Kinder zu unterrichten kannst so
nicht laufen das bayerische
Kultusministerium teilt uns schriftlich
mit dem Fall von Frau Schmidt gehe alles
streng nach Recht und Gesetz zukünftig
wolle man aber Beamte im Ruhestand noch
besser über die Hinzuverdienstgrenze
informieren deshalb werde man eine
Strategie erarbeiten wie das
Beratungsangebot noch zielführender und
für die Betroffenen schnell und einfach
erfolgen kann insbesondere bei
Vertragsverlängerung erscheint eine
vorherige Information angebracht
Gertraud Schmidt hält das ganze
Verfahren für unsinnig
weil dadurch Menschen die Willen sind zu
arbeiten und ich sage auch noch die
qualifiziert sind für ihre Arbeit
abgeschreckt werden
Gertraud Schmidt hat das Geld zurück an
den Freistaat gezahlt weil es aber so
nicht bleiben können hat sie beim
Bayerischen Landtag eine Petition
eingereicht